NETO MARIN: When
it's about money,
it's important to make your
user's path straight and free
of any obstacle.
Hi, I'm Neto Marin,
and I'm going
to show you how to test
Android billing implementation.
If you're looking for an
introduction to Android billing
or how in-app billing
API in your app,
don't miss our
first two episodes.
Probably the first level of
testing you need should do
is testing early on development
using static billing response.
For static testing, there
are four types of response
that you need to make sure
are handled in your app.
Successful purchase an item,
when the purchase is canceled,
refunded purchase, and when
the item being purchased
was not listed in your
application's product list.
Each reserved product ID returns
a specific static response
from Google Play.
No money is transferred when
you're making a billing request
with the reserved product IDs.
These reserved product
IDs are ready to use.
You don't need to create them
inside Developer Console.
You just need to use
them in your simulations,
like android.test.purchased
or canceled,
refunded, and item_unavailable.
To do these early tests, make
sure you have a stable flow,
it's handling
correctly the response,
construct a normal
request purchase,
and use one of the
reserved product IDs.
And to run this test, you
must use a real device.
You can't use the emulator.
Now eventually,
you're going to need
to test your application
with live data.
To do this, use
test.purchases, which lets
authorized users purchase
your published in-app items
without any actual
charge to their accounts.
To authorize this account
as testers in the Developer
Console, locate the
license testing section,
add the software
testers to the Gmail
accounts with
testing access field.
For more information, see
Setting Up Test Accounts.
Once authorized, your
testers can make purchases
without being charged.
Test purchases are real orders,
and Google Play processes them
in the same way as the others.
Test orders are automatically
cancelled at 14 days.
And test subscriptions
purchase occur daily,
regardless of the product's
actual subscription period.
And before you
launch your app, it's
important to do an end-to-end
testing or purchase flow,
making actual in-app purchases.
Testing real in-app
purchases enables
you to test the real in-app
billing experience, including
the actual purchase and checkout
flow that the users will
experience in your application.
To run this test, your
app needs to be published
on alpha or beta channel.
With alpha/beta test
groups, your chosen testers
can install your
app from Google Play
and test your in-app products.
They can make a real
purchase with no charge
to their accounts using any of
their normal payment methods
in Google Play to
make purchases.
In addition, if an alpha
or beta user was previously
added as a tester using
Developer Console,
it will still make test
purchases, instead of
real purchase flow.
Check out the link
for more information
about alpha and beta channels.
And with these four episodes,
we close our journey
about in-app billing
API with four episodes.
Don't forget to check our
documentation and training
guides [INAUDIBLE]
out any time you need.
And download the
Trivial Drive simple app
that can help you a
lot as a [INAUDIBLE]
and with convenience
class ready to use.
Now looking forward to
see you making money
with in-app billing API.
Thanks for watching.
Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]